when you don't have unlimited money or
any money in 2023 and you are trying to
sell [__] the number one thing on earth
is organic social media at scale because
it's [__] free and I mean like 19
posts a day or you're stuck in the spot
that you're in now which is you're
begging for a [__] miracle that
someone's gonna give you cash yeah and
just pitch competitions with that money
moves up if you flipped it and just
understood you're 100 in control [__] a
competition
[__] a VC [__] everybody
[__] up DC [__] everybody if you just
understand that you're fully in control
and you just have to pound social and
start googling how to make the best
Shopify site selling T-shirts enter
literally that [__] is out there yeah
for free best practices